Jen are you a writer I am NOT I am an
author it's interesting because people
ask me all the time and it catches me
off guard and I have to remember that
yes I've written three books I am an
author so I am a writer in that sense I
am NOT a screenwriter so what is it that
you do aside from the books I'm a
speaker I am a blogger for the
Huffington Post I am a writing
instructor for writers on the verge at
MBC I've been a writing instructor there
for eight years and I'm a story career
consultant at Jen Grisanti consultancy
when someone approaches you through your
website yeah and they say I'm
considering hiring you how can you
determine the difference between a
writer that's dabbling in the industry
versus those who say this is my chosen
career path and you can tell the
difference in terms of their level of
commitment yes I you know it's
interesting I mean I get writers from
coming out of college to a co-executive
producer staff writer all the way up to
co-executive producer level this is
because I was a former 12-year studio
executive and when I was an executive I
staffed over 15 top primetime TV shifts
and I got to know a lot of writers so
that that allowed me whereas I know a
lot of consultants get the brand brand
new writers but because I've been
exposed to the professional writer I do
get a lot of professional writers I
think my feeling is like a part of being
a current programming executive really
was identifying new voices so I like
working with the green writer who hasn't
developed bad habits and who is open to
the process so I really don't have a
problem if I have someone
who is dabbling versus totally committed
as long as they are committed to the
process process that they sign on for
you said something that caught my ear
and that was bad habits yeah so in terms
of being an established writer or
someone who's done it for several years
and has quote their way what are some
different tip offs where you see okay
this person's more clothes sort of you
know arms and and not open to the past
yeah there are many pitfalls I would say
probably the biggest tip-off is the
inability to hear a note before
defending it up so I think like the
biggest tip-off well I mean the first
tip-off is on the page when you can tell
in the first three pages if a writer
knows how to write really has but what I
can say is you can also tell a voice and
you can have a writer who has a voice
but doesn't have the formatting down but
the voice can still be heard through the
bad formatting so that's why I say I'm
open and I have no problem working with
brand new writers I love that I also
love working with produce writers who
who do have a stronger sense of the
craft however the the gift is really in
recognizing when you have the newer
writer who makes faux pause like
defending a note before hearing a note
which is a very big mistake that many
newer newer writers make it also is a
mistake that writers make on staff and
and so it really is helping them to feel
safe so that when you're giving a note
and and I can say when I was a studio
executive the agenda was that of the net
work in the studio that I was carrying
and giving notes whereas as a story
career consultant independently I have
no agenda other than making the story
the best that it could be so this is why
I encourage writers to be open and to
recognize my only goal is to make their
story the best that it can be you said
something earlier about you can overlook
maybe formatting if the voice is strong
and authentic does that mean if the
story is original or it has nothing to
do with that no it does you know voice
comes down to so many different things
and I like a voice could come down to a
character description it could come down
to writing poetic and lyrical action
lines it could come down to the original
concept it could come down to knowing
how to write a flawed character well I
mean there are so many I
I always try to figure out if I could
really pinpoint what voice is and and
help people understand and I think for
me a large way that I explain voice is
the idea of what is your world view what
has happened to you in your life that
has caused you pain and given you
something to say and how does your
writing reflect that
have you ever seen someone be too
emotional and to because we all feel
that our story is is intense and it is
because we've lived it but I've you ever
seen it in the writing where maybe toned
down whatever it is the anger and that
scene oh yeah something I mean I would
say a much greater problem is not enough
emotion I think the too much emotion is
not near as common is the how do we
elevate the emotion so that we feel this
more and when you see that do you feel
like that person's phoning in that
character it's like a filler or or is it
that maybe they're not totally in touch
oh I think that comes from being green
and not really understanding I think
there's so much that goes into strong
character work I I work with writers on
the idea of thinking about the wound
thinking about the childhood wound and
how the in a TV pilot how the series
trigger splits open that wound and then
the idea of what is the negative
narrative that has come from that wound
and how is that getting in the way of
the central character achieving the goal
and then how through the pursuit is the
central character one step toward
healing that wound
you